have you seen the instagram challenge
this is we talked about this on the show
yesterday it's the challenge
where women just post selfies of
themselves on instagram
as though that were challenging well it
turns out
that all of us may be inadvertently
participating in the instagram challenge
because it turns out instagram might be
spying on us
all the time people found this out
because of an update
to the ios on their on their smartphones
on their apple so they download ios 14
beta and it shows you with a little
indicator light whenever your phone
camera is being accessed by apps that
maybe you didn't think were accessing
your phone's camera and as users are
scrolling through instagram
they see the light come on i hope you're
looking hot
i hope you're posing for your challenge
now instagram denies all this you see
it was just a big misunderstanding
there's a little problem with the code
there's no
nothing to worry about we're totally not
spying on you
all the time everywhere well
if you believe that my friends i think
i've got a bridge in brooklyn
to sell you big tech has got a lot of
power
a lot a lot of power they were dragged
in front of capitol hill yesterday
we will examine their testimony and
examine why we all need to
turn off tune out and drop in
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show uh yesterday i
was going through the comments on
youtube
and rob i think summed it up pretty well
when we were looking at the testimony of
bill barr
or the attempted testimony of bill barr
in front of congress he said
a guy who cross-examines criminals for a
living being cross-examined by a bunch
of criminals
it's no wonder this did not go well no
wonder
at all does remind me when i look at the
democrats trying to grill these people
of a sort of a crime family
something something like that something
really nefarious going on
though frankly sometimes the republicans
are no better and i think this came out
especially
when we saw those big tech zillionaire
oligarchs
testifying yesterday where does the
power
really exist in the united states
where forget even just political power
the power to look at you
listen to you push you in certain
directions
figure out what kind of information
you're seeing that's a lot of power
and i think it's time to take some of
that back first though we gotta thank
our friends
over at rock auto you know it can be
very frustrating
it can take hours just to get a simple
thing fixed
on your car well fortunately
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years that makes the whole process
very simple and reliably inexpensive
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best of
all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts like for instance if
you get me you know i go into a
brick-and-mortar auto parts store
they think there's my mark there's a guy
who doesn't know anything about cars
i'm gonna go online and order the part
then it's going to come in later i'm
going to charge them double
probably they ordered it from
rockauto.com well i'll tell you the rock
auto catalog is so easy to navigate
even i can do it which is shocking it's
unbelievable
go to rockauto.com right now see all of
the parts available
for your car or truck right noel's know
w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about xbox so
that they know
that we sent you
although probably in the future we're
not even gonna have to do any of that
because the big tech oligarchs are going
to know where we are
all the time they're going to know what
we're thinking they're going to read our
thoughts you know
we all have these stories of how creepy
it's getting with our smartphones
for instance when the lockdown was
actually in
place and if you wanted to violate it
you could only go to a few friends
houses
i found out sweet little lisa and i
basically were only going
to one friend's house every saturday
night
and you start going a few times and then
eventually
maybe after the third or fourth time i
look at my phone it gets to be four or
five o'clock they say hey michael
are you ready to go to jonathan's house
here's the it's 40 minutes to this
address and you think oh my gosh you
know where i am all the time
you can predict where i'm going and
actually in recent years big tech
has disabled some features that were
scaring people into realizing how much
they know about us how much they can
predict what we're doing
the trouble is look we we all hate
politicians
right but at least our politicians have
some accountability to us
politically under the law big tech i'm
not so sure about that
i don't know that big tech has our
interests at heart i don't think big
tech has our personal interests in heart
i don't think big tech has our national
interests at heart i think they have
with maybe one exception very very
very little loyalty to the united states
the country
that allowed their companies to thrive
so the ceos yesterday of apple
google facebook and amazon were hauled
in front of congress
they were asked for testimony they got
to give a little bit more testimony than
bill barr did two days ago
specifically though they were asked if
they think
china is stealing from u.s
firms very simple question do you
believe china steals
u.s technology we all know that's true
we've known that's true for decades
we've all admitted that that is true for
decades so can these zillionaire
oligarchs
some of whom rely on chinese slave labor
to build their products
can those ceos admit
what china's up to for most of them
absolutely not
i don't know of specific cases where we
have been stolen from uh by the
government
so you don't believe that the chinese
government's stealing technology from
u.s companies or you're just saying that
not from yours
and i'm saying i i know of no case on
hours where it occurred which is i can
only speak to firsthand knowledge
mr pichai do you believe that the
chinese government steals technology
from united states companies
uh congressman um i have no firsthand
knowledge of
uh any information stolen from google
district mr zuckerberg
uh congressman i think it's well
documented that the chinese government
steals technology from american
companies
no thank you mr bezos
you're on mute mr bezos i believe you're
on mute i'm sorry i've seen i have
heard many reports of that and i i
haven't seen it personally but i've
heard many reports of it
so even beyond their answers to that i
love that the ceo
of the largest company ever practically
amazon
doesn't know how to unmute his
microphone when he's giving
congressional testimony that just
that's perfect of all those guys starts
out with tim cook moves on to sundar
pichai at google then mark zuckerberg at
facebook
then finally jeff bezos at amazon
only one of them was willing to admit
that china steals u.s technology which
we we've all known for years
you got to give credit where credit's
due to mark zuckerberg of all these guys
zuckerberg is far and away the best of
them
he is the most defensible and i got a
lot of problems with facebook
but at least this guy is willing to say
he seems actually kind of shocked when
he hears the other ceo he goes
um yeah i think we can we can admit
right that china's stealing our attack
like we know
like why are we trying the rest of these
guys they're like a bunch of perps who
just got caught
say i do i have no firsthand knowledge i
have none
what are you china no china's good we
love you xi jinping keep
keep giving us those slaves to build our
products we we love you haha
yeah we hate hong kong yeah it's it's
pathetic
it's pathetic and there are
there are two angles to this one is we
need our companies to be patriotic
we need there is nothing conservative
about allowing companies that have
thrived in your country
to transcend all bonds of loyalty
to your country and in some cases to
actively undermine
your country there's nothing
conservative i know conservatives have
kind of bought into this idea
that we need to support corporate
america at all costs you know corporate
america is what corporate america is
terrible okay
corporate america maybe more than any
institution
other than the higher education
apparatus
is pushing america to the left because
all they care about is the almighty
dollar there's nothing conservative
about chasing the almighty dollar for
itself
and that's it just make money money
money money without any higher end
in sight there's nothing conservative
about that it's very modern
it's very lib it's very left-wing to do
that it's very materialist
to do that kind of thing and we should
not tolerate it but the bigger point
here
beyond all of that is these guys have
too much power whether or not instagram
is actually spying on you maybe it is
just a bug in the system
it could be what do i know i haven't
looked into the code
probably though i don't think that's the
case probably a lot of these apps
are spying on us a lot of the time and
even if the apps aren't
people can hack in pretty easily okay
and and
these guys these big tech oligarchs are
controlling the apparatus with which
they do that
they have too much power they're
unaccountable they've bought off much of
congress
of both parties and they need to be
reined in
okay it's not even just the companies
themselves
our reliance on technology on the
digital world
is making us susceptible to all sorts of
deception even outside of the digital
world
right now there's a major push by the
left to try to steal this election
by pushing nationwide mail-in ballots
the left has been caught red-handed
using using mail-in ballots and other
schemes as a means of voter fraud
for a very long time they've been doing
it forever they're actually
in one of the biographies of lbj fdr
jokes to lbj about how you got to
remember to steal some ballots and play
with the vote tally at the end if you
want to win elections
okay there's nothing new about that what
is new is americans thinking
that it's normal to be able to just 100
of people vote by mail and nothing is
going to happen there there's a reason
that we have polling places there's a
reason we have an election day
there's a reason that we have ballot
security people show up
at these polling places because
people are trying to manipulate you
people are trying to steal your vote
people are trying to suppress your vote
okay and there's something that feels
very
good it makes us feel very secure in
putting in our ballot at a polling
station
many conservatives have been
disfranchised before this has happened
to me personally
i voted in a primary and then magically
for some reason i was kicked off the
voter roll for the general election
okay we all know people have these
stories so you want to make sure your
ballot is secure
well a local cbs affiliate in new york
took on a little experiment to see just
how secure mail and ballots are
the results will terrify you but first
gotta thank our friends over at lifelock
speaking of security
criminals do not care what is going on
okay they don't they're not going to
take pity on you because this oh you
know what there's covid going on
there's a lockdown so we're not going to
steal your stuff anymore i don't think
so
they are going to steal your information
and you need to protect your information
you need to be responsible
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has been
potentially compromised they will send
you an alert
if you become a victim of identity theft
lifelock can help you
restore your identity easier than what
you can do on your own
a lot of people spying on you a lot of
people getting into your data okay
make sure you protect yourself no one
can prevent all identity theft
or monitor all transactions at all
businesses lifelock can see threats that
you might miss
on your own join now and save up to 25
percent off your first year go to
lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com
knowlescanerwlis
for 25 off head on over there at this
this time maybe more than ever a lot of
us
are susceptible to invasions of our
privacy and even identity theft
lifelock.com
knowles so a cbs affiliate
in new york does a little experiment
they take a hundred ballots
they put them in the mail their mock-up
ballots
and they send them to a p.o box that
they've registered for this experiment
everyone's vote get gets counted right
everything's totally fine hunky dory
not quite if you know how to mail a
letter
you already know how to mail in your
vote
thank you very much but how long might
it take for that vote to actually arrive
and be counted are you welcome have a
good afternoon we decided to test it
sending a hundred mock ballots
simulating a hundred voters
from locations all across philadelphia
to a p.o box we set up to represent a
local election office
a couple days later we mailed a hundred
more using the same size envelopes
and the same class of mail as real
ballots here
to approximate the weight we even folded
mock votes into every one
in the following week we checked our p.o
box for the results
mail pickup notice there's more when we
went to collect everything though
most of our votes seem to be lost that's
all i have back there right now
i'm sure you're totally sure i believe
in you all right
okay take care so it turned up short
i also should point out i pulled a
little bit of a joe biden there i
thought it was from new york but it was
from
philly we'll get to joe biden making a
much more egregious error than that in a
moment because frankly
i consider philadelphia to be a suburb
of new york anyway
but it didn't wherever they are it
didn't work and we still don't know
where a lot of those ballots are
they couldn't find some then they did
find the ballots finally
at the at the po box then
the the investigative journalists who
tried this experiment
ended up getting someone else's mail
they ended up getting two
birthday cards in there so i don't know
where the where their mail went but they
got two birthday cards
21 of the
100 ballots mock ballots that they
mailed out had not made it to the po box
after four days not it's not that far to
travel
some were missing after more than a week
three out of 100 of the ballots were
just completely lost
three percent right they mailed hundred
three get lost
do you think three percent could swing
an election
i think it could of course it could our
elections are razor thin
for the last 20 years anyway absolutely
three percent could
they're expecting right now 80 to 100
million
voters to vote by mail so you're looking
at just just using this one little
experiment as a test
three million votes could go missing
and don't forget only half the country
less than half the country votes
that's a huge percentage of people
it's not secure here in california as of
the last couple years
they now list your party registration
on the outside of the envelope in other
words now that now that we've got
voter harvesting throughout a lot of the
country people will come they'll take a
look at that envelope and say oh
republican ballot
whoops got lost lost in the mail things
get lost in the mail all the time
i want what happens if just like the
birthday card
issue here someone else gets your ballot
they don't agree with the positions you
hold
they can see your party registration on
the outside
might just go missing this is what the
left is pushing for rife for abuse
some democratic congress lady asked
attorney general barry yesterday
said do you have any evidence that there
could be fraud involved in the mail-in
ballots and he said i don't have
evidence i have common sense
of course it could even the fact that
the news agency was making all these
fake ballots that looked really really
really real should give us some pause
here
but how else are democrats going to
steal this election they can't they
can't
rely on their candidate their candidate
doesn't know where he is
forget about confusing a certain cbs
affiliate
this guy will actually show up to a
place fly in
drive in get to a podium start to give a
speech and have no clue where he is and
worse than that this happens sometimes
in politics
he doesn't even know how to cover for it
anymore take a listen to the latest
greatest hit
from presumptive democratic nominee joe
biden
good afternoon everyone welcome to
kingswood community center
actually that's the one down i used to
work as a joke
you know where you were anyway it's uh
it's great to be here oh that is
sad that is very sad because he walks up
there
like i don't know i don't know what the
joke would be if that were a joke
that he he just got confused right he's
someplace and i guess it's near where he
used to be and then he says
uh we're here at kingman community
center oh wait a second that's
i'm not i'm not there where am i i don't
i'm just joking
just joking definitely not in cognitive
decline
anyway let's move on with the show so he
forgot where he
was he then forgot where president trump
wasn't
it is not a good idea evidence the fact
that
due rhetorical question i'm not
expecting an answer do you think the
president all of a sudden decided not to
go to tallahassee
because he no longer he thought it was
the interest of the public
he's decided for jacksonville i mean
jacksonville florida
so he was referring to the president now
moving the republican national
convention from jacksonville florida
maybe back to charlotte maybe back to
the white house who knows
but he didn't even remember where that
was going to be and it's
oh we're having an earthquake right now
at the daily wire
it's amazing i hope we don't fall
through the floor that's uh
gosh i made 2020 just can't get any
crazier can it
so in any case back to joe biden joe
biden couldn't even
remember that where the rnc was going to
be then it wasn't going to be
and beyond his inability to remember
where we are
joe biden can't formulate the sentences
that will allow him to either get out of
these gaffes or even
or even just get a coherent idea apart
that's probably the saddest part of it
right
he's just kind of trailing off and oh
yeah sorry i don't know he's he's not
even finishing his sentences they're
just
sentence fragments he was leaving his
campaign office the other day
one of his campaign staffers had to lead
him out
almost holding his hand she
you can see it's a young staffer and
he's kind of
he's looking in other directions and
she's she's
holding him like it's her grandpa like
you you know okay come here grandpa
don't nope don't talk to the reporters
the minute the reporters put a
microphone in front of
his face she says okay thanks guys thank
you thank you bye-bye get in the car joe
come on we can't have you talking to
reporters
so they they cannot campaign
out in the open right they won't they
won't talk to reporters every every time
they do speak to anybody it's got to be
highly manicured highly uh tied up
this ties in with big tech because what
we have is a virtual
campaign and a virtual campaign can be
manipulated
just like a deep fake video just like a
photoshopped photograph
it can be manipulated and manicured to
give the illusion of something
that it's not if joe biden had to
campaign in person in
real life where we all ought to be
living in real life where we're flesh
and blood and we're moving around and
we're held accountable for doing real
things
he wouldn't stand a chance trump would
win 50 states and
end greenland you'd win 51 states once
we annexed greenland
but because these masters of the
universe
can create using joe biden's image they
can create
a candidate out of whole cloth he
actually might stand a chance
joe biden also just put out this
statement
i'm sure he didn't write it i'm sure he
didn't even read it but he put out a
statement
to try to win over some of those voters
in the middle he said quote
i have said from the outset of recent
protests that there is no place for
violence and destruction of property
peaceful protesters should be protected
and arsonists and anarchists
should be prosecuted so he's taking this
stand he's moderating for the general
he's saying yeah we don't
we don't want to burn down the country
why is he doing that because two days
ago
trump launched the most devastating ad
that he has yet
on the biden campaign which is if you
elect joe biden
you're going to get robbed if you elect
joe biden the cops are going to get
defunded
democrats are dangerous that was the
message for the last few months the
trump campaign has been dithering the
trump campaign has been attacking joe
for being too conservative
they've attacked joe for being too tough
on crime it's just ridiculous it was
very ineffective
so the biden campaign didn't care very
much now though the trump campaign is
getting serious
and so biden is moderating too and he's
actually uh
it seems leaning toward picking a cop
to be his vp not a real cop but but
someone with a reputation of a cop
former california attorney general
kamala harris
now how do we know that joe biden is
leading toward kamala harris because
politico
accidentally broke the news in very
explicit terms
and then they tried to pretend in our
digital age where you can memory whole
anything that oh it was just uh yeah
that was just a formatting error
never mind nothing to see here we'll get
into their announcement that was not an
announcement
then we will get into where trump stands
on all of this but first i got to thank
our friends over at buttercloth
if you're watching the show right now
you see that i'm wearing a very
very sexy shirt i don't know i don't
know how else to put it
dapper or a dapper doesn't quite sum it
all up i'm wearing a lovely shirt
by buttercloth a young fashion designer
came here from vietnam
he invented a fabric so revolutionary it
caught the attention of shark tank
where robert loved it so much he
invested
a quarter million dollars developing a
profoundly
soft fabric using a special blend
of 100 long fiber cotton
and unique manufacturing processes
buttercloth has made
the best feeling shirt ever you know i
often wear sweaters on this show
because i like to be a little bit
comfortable okay sometimes those
those oxford shirts they can feel stiff
they can feel uncomfortable
buttercloth i've never felt anything
like it and it's not even like it's some
crazy synthetic
you know thing it's this amazing
technology with cotton and then the
shirt the shirt i'm wearing in
particular
has this icy cool feel to it where they
use organic mint fibers and you put it
on your skin
and it feels it it actually gives you
almost like a little bit of a chill
it cools you down i didn't believe it
was going to work then i tried it on i
was shocked
really really great for summer and
they've got really great style as
as you can see buttercloth is offering
right now to our listeners 20
off your first purchase go to
buttercloth.com knowlescannerwlis
receive 20 off your first full price
order it is the softest oxford shirt
you've ever it's
you've got to try to believe it
buttercloth.com
knowles canada w-l-e-s
so politico puts this
out on their website quote joe biden
chose kamala harris to become his
running mate for the 2020 election on
august 1st
two weeks before the democratic national
convention after keeping his choice
close to the chest for months
in his announcement biden called harris
a worthy opponent and a worthy running
mate
alluding to the pair's rivalry during
the earlier stages of the democratic
primary
she will bring her experience as a
prosecutor household name recognition
and skill
as a debater to the ticket
so politico walks this back because as
you might notice it's not august first
yet
so how do what what is this announcement
joe biden hasn't announced anything to
my knowledge
they said oh that's just placeholder
text
you know i've i've worked around
newspapers and websites and politics
very bit
that ain't placeholder text that's not
placeholder text actually is this kind
of nonsense latin
which is called it's called lorem ipsum
and it's just kind of nonsense latin
that you
fill in sometimes so you can figure out
how things are going to be spaced out on
a page
you don't get very very specific about
who
joe biden chooses for his running mate
and how he chose her
and when he did it and what the quotes
were
seems to me the campaign is leaning
heavily in her direction
though with all of the leaks about
kamala harris
they're clearly taking the temperature
and maybe some people are working
against her on the campaign
in any case joe biden is getting pretty
serious
they will because of the extended
lockdowns be able to craft whatever
image they want you don't need to worry
so much about the gaps on the campaign
trail
this will only favor the left because
the big tech masters of the universe
only favor the left whenever there's a
little accident a little glitch a little
bug
and you know some search results i don't
know there's search engine manipulation
and
all the left-wing sites seem to pop up
but not the right-wing sites or there
will be some terrible
defamation of a conservative on the
internet but then they'll get rid of it
all those
accidents all those glitches only seem
to go in one
direction expect that to get much much
worse
as november approaches so then we get to
the question president trump what should
he do about this
right now it would seem president trump
is leaning in the direction of giving a
virtual convention speech
from the white house or wherever that's
a bad idea
it's a very bad idea i said it from the
very beginning
coronavirus is the campaign for
democrats
what i mean by that is that the the
consequences of the virus
the lockdowns the mail-in votes
everywhere the digital everything
that is the campaign that is their
strategy
to retake the white house if trump plays
into that
he is handing them the campaign he's
handing them the election
don't play into that i think president
trump
needs to go to charlotte or or
jacksonville i guess they're pulled out
of there but go to charlotte probably
or wherever give a speech in person
to real people waving real trump signs
wearing real maga hats cheering in real
time he needs the rallies the president
needs the rallies that's the campaign
and he is being hoodwinked by a liberal
media
and technological establishment and
political establishment and public
health
establishment he's being hoodwinked into
giving up his campaign the strongest
assets he has
for re-election and giving it over to
digital manipulators who can make joe
biden look like he can
string three words together he should
not play into that
okay we got it we got a two now we got
it we got to get we cannot
live our lives exclusively on technology
technology can be incredibly useful i
think conservatives have benefited from
it greatly it's allowed us to get past
the gatekeepers of the mainstream media
we should use it wisely
we cannot give ourselves over to it
entirely
that would be to give over our politics
to the left
and specifically to unaccountable
oligarchs who not only don't care about
us they don't care about our country
they are chasing the almighty dollar all
the way to slave labor in china
that is not the american dream president
trump just got in trouble actually for
talking about the american dream
he rescinded an obama-era housing rule
that was extraordinarily stupid and
ineffective and and even if it were
to be effective not particularly
desirable
and so president trump pulls this out
and he says quote i'm happy to inform
all of the people
living their suburban lifestyle dream
caps on sld for some reason that you
will no longer be bothered or
financially hurt by having low income
housing built in your neighborhood
your housing prices will go up based on
the market crime will go down
i've rescinded the obama biden affh rule
enjoy great stuff love this idea of
course they called him a racist they
call them a racist to be sneezes
this is a great idea this obama rule
from 2015
allowed the federal government to
withhold funding if it doesn't like
how state and local governments are
tinkering with
low-income housing in any neighborhood
it wants that's obviously
an extraordinary power grab by the
federal government
ben carson at the head of of housing and
urban development
suggested that this might happen just uh
just a little while
ago his comments were quote after
reviewing thousands of comments on the
proposed changes to the affirmatively
furthering fair housing regulation we
found it to be unworkable ultimately a
waste of time for localities to comply
with
too often resulting in funds being
steered away from communities that need
them most
so then they come out they rescind this
rule i think it's a wonderful idea
trump's gotta go for the suburbs and the
way he's gonna win over the suburbs is
not playing nice there's some people
especially on the right who say the way
that trump's got to win the suburbs
is he's got to become liberal and he's
got to
be become a wimp and he's got to give in
to the democrats no
it's not how you're going to win the
suburbs you know you know how you win
the suburbs bring down crime
make people feel safe bring law and
order
you always hear that we're losing
suburban women when push comes to shove
especially in presidential election
years
suburban women tend to vote with their
husbands okay so you gotta
win the suburbs generally and the way
you win the suburbs
is by being normal okay you don't need
to be some extreme right-wing ideologue
you certainly shouldn't be an extreme
left-wing ideologue just be normal and
protect people's
lives and property and speak to them in
a direct way the way that got president
trump the white house the first time
around
and you will win the suburbs and i think
trump campaign is finally starting to do
that i think that's a good thing
that should strongly be encouraged
you know right now on i was reading vice
why was i reading vice i have no idea
i was reading vice dot com and there's a
phenomenon going on on the left it's
called
woke fishing have you heard about this
say have you been woke fished while
dating here's how to tell
there's a gal who's writing serena smith
she says when i was 17 i decided to go
vegan
okay and i mentioned my new veganism to
the guy i was seeing at the time
17 okay and to my surprise he seemed
really annoyed
he responded with an uninterruptible
lecture on the importance of supporting
british farmers
i can still remember one of his appalled
patronizing texts oh no you're not going
to become one of those vegan feminists
are you
i was confused he hadn't come across
like someone who hated vegan feminists
so where had this come from woke fishing
woke fishing put simply is when people
masquerade as holding progressive
political views
to ensnare potential partners a woke
fish may at first present themselves
as a protest attending sex-positive
anti-racist
intersectional feminist who drinks
ethically sourced
oat milk and has read the back catalog
of audre lorde twice but in reality
they don't give an s-h-i-t or as is
often the case
they are actively the opposite in their
personal lives it's like catfishing
but specifically with political beliefs
uh
this this is terrific stuff i absolutely
love that even the left is waking up to
this
first of all what this woman doesn't
understand is that every male feminist
every male vegan every male leftist
activist
is just doing it to pick up
chicks that's it the the male feminists
they're the creepiest men on the planet
stay away from them
they're they're pretending to be
effeminate
they're pretending to appeal to you
they're just trying to get you into bed
that's all it is
okay you shouldn't fall for it
that that that's true in the real world
too but this especially seems to be true
on the internet where people can
manicure their own profiles and make
them seem to be something
that they are not well that's what's
going on
we as a as a fact of the internet are
always
we we have much more control in making
ourselves seem to be something
that we are not much harder to do that
in real life though
everyone does that to a certain degree
as well but on the internet they do that
especially it's not just on politics
it's even in your personal life okay
we need to be a little bit wary of that
we need to realize when we talk about
ideology there's a big difference
between the fantasy of the left and the
reality
that we see all around us big difference
between ideological theories and common
sense
the internet magnifies that times a
zillion
because you you know getting back to our
instagram challenge you can
take the picture to make you look any
way you want the picture to make you
look
and you can airbrush it and you can have
them say anything we need to avoid this
in politics we need to avoid this
in our personal lives as well use
technology when it's advantageous to us
but as a broader rule for our lives tune
out unplug dig into the real world
otherwise we've lost already
we've got to get to the mailbag though
i've got to tell you head on over
to the michael knowles show youtube
channel we've got interviews we've got
reaction videos we have short
short segments from the show and be on a
lookout this saturday my interview
with ryan long who is the comedian who
did that viral video
when wokes and racists actually agree on
everything that'll be up on saturday
and uh we'll have a teaser of that
interview coming out on friday also by
ben's book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps you can get it it's terrific
a really enjoyable read head on over
there and get a daily wire
reader's pass uh one dollar for your
first month
and three bucks a month after that what
else what else are we selling oh yeah
check out uh
when the spacex shuttle will be landing
this sunday august 2nd
which will be the first time that spacex
will have completed a successful crude
mission to the international space
station
we will be live streaming it across
youtube facebook and dailywire.com with
a special all-access
from daily wire god king jeremy boring
who loves outer space so you can join
and chat with him all about that
head on over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with the mailbag
all right let's jump in from brad dear
michael this past weekend you said you
would no longer watch the new york
yankees after the entire team knelt
during the black ribbon ceremony on
opening day
i wanted you to know nearly the entire
boston red sox team
stood during their opening day ceremony
will you see the light and become a red
sox fan
i would rather die than become a red sox
fan
i don't care how angry i am at the
yankees i'm the yankees are dead to me
but i sure ain't gonna become a red sox
come on i've got some dignity i've got
some patriotism and a love of new york
left absolutely not
nice try though from hugh dock hi
michael i loved your response to joe
rogan's take on video games you spoke
about how
throughout history great thinkers
considered leisure to be an important
use of time and that we've lost a lot of
our appreciation for leisure in today's
culture
what are your favorite leisurely
activities or what leisurely activities
would you recommend to someone trying to
implement more leisure time
in their life how many times can we say
leisure one thing i would recommend
is a nice cigar every so often i did
this last night
with our pals uh jonathan hay
and uh drew clavin you know i go to
drew's house a fair bit
and have a nice cigar and maybe a scotch
or two or three or
25. and so that's a nice activity it's
cigars are great i'm not even joking
about the cigar the cigar is great as a
leisure activity
because it it tunes you into your taste
so you're you are kind of experiencing
this aesthetic thing
but you can either do it on your own and
when you when you smoke a cigar alone it
forces you to sit down and contemplate
for 40 minutes or 45 minutes it's very
helpful
and you can do it as a social activity
and it is an aid to conversation
and i don't just mean like hey how are
the kids or did you see what susie did
the other day
i mean real conversation where you're
talking about real things that that
develop your mind and your spirit
and the way that the ancient greeks
would have you know the way that this is
described in kind of plato
is the idea that you're you're having a
like you kind of have an intellectual
child with the person you're conversing
with you know the
kind of product of your two ideas and
conversations coming together will will
produce this intellectual job that's
very important i really like that
reading obviously though reading is not
particularly relaxing but it is a
is a leisure activity that will develop
you uh going to church
highly recommend going to church you
know the body is a temple the temple
needs incense so you've got to smoke the
stogies you should go to church as well
i mean contemplating god is sort of
the definition of a leisure activity or
and we're using leisure not in the way
that modern people use it but
in the higher sense of that so you
should be going to church you should be
praying you should be
reading the scripture you should be
thinking about god that's the
probably the highest end of the
contemplative life you can paint i enjoy
painting every now and again
i'm not exactly caravaggio but i sure do
enjoy it that's that's a great leisure
activity that allows you to see
something new
really focus on color really focus on
where we are in the world
i'm all for the hustle you know i work a
pretty long work day
and but you can't only do that
i mean even if you're working 12 or 14
hour work day
you need some leisure time to to
contemplate
the eternal things it'll make you better
at your grind in your hustle first of
all
and will make you a full fuller human
person from alex
after a recent breakup i'm doubting the
institution of marriage being a viable
and reasonable outcome for men in
today's society
women are more likely to initiate a
divorce and when they do the divorce
hearings drastically tip in favor of
women
when it comes to custody not only that
but they also take at least 50 percent
of everything we've made for the family
how can men expect to enter a marriage
when they want a family and a lifelong
partner but those things are now harder
and harder to hold on to
my very practical advice is be catholic
and i say that because if you are
catholic and you're like
really catholic like you actually
practice it and you believe the stuff
and you do this stuff
you cannot get divorced it is not
permitted
you would have to abandon your faith to
be divorced it is not accepted you know
christ
is very clear in matthew no divorce you
can't do it
obviously there are people who would
call themselves or consider themselves
catholic who do get divorced and
and remarried but uh it's not you're not
allowed to do that so that would be one
thing that would increase your chances
of of
having a happy marriage now there are
many non-catholics who have happy
marriages
as well you've got to make sure that you
share at least the basic
value that divorce is not an option
you're in it you're in it for life there
was something actually sort of charming
about will smith and jada pinkett's
marriage they had this
bizarre conversation about their
marriage the other day and
they said yeah i cheated on you and i
cheated and it was terrible and
it was a very hard marriage and i
thought it was on the ropes but we're
not getting divorced
and they quoted bad boys they
paraphrased bad boys they said we ride
together we died together bad marriage
for life
there's actually something kind of
admirable about that i wish they didn't
have a bad marriage but there's
something admirable about saying
we're not getting divorced it's just not
going to happen
so we got to figure out this marriage i
think there is
much greater hope but you're not going
to find it in the
kind of regular liberal secular pop
culture where marriage is just treated
as
a slightly more serious relationship in
line with all of your other romantic
relationships and you should follow your
your romantic love wherever it goes
you you almost certainly will need to
marry someone who's quite religious
uh you'll have to marry someone who's
constitutionally conservative i don't
mean that like the document the
constitution i mean
their own personal constitution has to
be moderate and conservative so they're
not
taken to flights of fancy like leaving
you for the secretary or something
and you're you're going to have to
spell out what the marriage is at the
outset we always talk about how we have
to be specific with words
well marriage has been redefined and
redefined ad nauseum in the last 60
years
you got to make sure that you're
entering into the same institution that
your
future spouse thinks they're entering
into but i think there is hope you just
gotta find
a good spouse from cara what a great
name
dear michael knowles people i thought i
knew my whole life are coming out on
social media completely believing
fake news 100 and the scary part is if
you show them the truth they get angry
there's no middle ground for
conversation the truth is they're
delusional and at least they
at the least they're narrow-minded do i
turn the other cheek forgive them for
they know not what they do
and keep my mouth shut with while their
lips flap lies and demand justice over
whatever their soup of the day is
sincerely kara an outcast from new york
you got to be wise as a serpent and
innocent as a dove
if you think it will be productive for
you to call out a lie and you think you
can do so in a way
that's not going to completely destroy
the relationship
then i would insert yourself or if you
were asked your opinion you should
certainly say what your opinion is you
should have integrity about that
but sometimes the problem runs a little
bit deeper you're not going to be able
to change someone's mind by just picking
apart every little thing that rachel
maddow says
on msnbc you're going to have to get
down to basics first principles
beyond you know tax rates and china
policy
you've got to get down to what is
america
what is the human person what is our
relationship to government what are we
here for
how did we come to be i mean like really
basic questions cardinal manning a great
political thinker said
at bottom all human conflict is
theological you've got to get down to
the basics of where they're
getting their political views and if you
can get them
dislodged from some of the leftist or
liberal lies that undergird their
political views
then you might be able to change their
opinions even on the fake news itself
from joel austere religious podcaster my
wife and i are coming up on our first
anniversary
since we got married we have been
discussing when they begin
when to begin having children as a
catholic i've been wanting to accept
children as they come
my wife a methodist has always wanted to
wait a little while
we originally decided that we would wait
a year before really trying to have our
first child
but with that year ending in the current
political climate she's begun to
question whether or not we should wait a
little longer
her fear is that if things get really
bad then our lives
and livelihoods could become quickly
endangered and we would be unable to
support our new child
i've made the argument that child
bearing and rearing is the highest
calling of a married couple and that to
accept
a certain level of risk is always
present in this endeavor do you think i
should continue trying to convince
her to start having children soon or
should i acquiesce to her in this
do not acquiesce to your wife what is
wrong with you
you're right your wife is wrong it's as
simple as that have kids you should have
started having kids on day one
but better late than never do it just do
it
first of all if you're if you're using
contraception within marriage
you are at a very basic level
withholding
something from your spouse
we don't need to get into specifics here
all right this is not an r or
x rated show but you you see what i'm
saying that that
has symbolic significance that you're
withholding something
you ought to give to the spouse totally
and you ought to be open to life
you as a catholic believe that as i do
your wife is a methodist maybe he
doesn't i understand that
plenty of couples contracept and they've
come to this understanding together
and maybe they don't want to have kids
and i guess that's the
that's the decision that they have made
fine i
i get that but you have a disagreement
here and you you actually have a
religious disagreement which is
you you ought to try to have kids by the
way not everybody gets to have kids
and for people who are trying to have
kids sometimes it doesn't happen right
away okay a lot
i know a lot of young people who think
it's gonna happen right away and then it
doesn't
you gotta keep working on it maybe try a
different angle i don't know there are a
lot of things you can try
but you should get started right away it
is good it is objectively
good to have children and it is
objectively bad
to try not to have children or to try
not to let your husband have children or
you know with you hopefully
it's that's that's a bad thing to close
yourself off from life
this argument that oh but it's crazy in
2020 yeah it's always crazy
ev politics is always crazy relatively
compared to
to most other times in history things
are kind of calm right now
have kids do it and also the other thing
is i mean
if you if you have this kind of
political or religious i guess
disagreement
on the kids thing at the very least you
can
you can point to genesis 3 and say that
you ought to be the head of the
household
and in as much as you're doing that have
the kids
and if you can't have kids maybe
consider adoption
and you know i mean look not not
everyone gets to have kids
but if you can you certainly should try
alright last one from daniel dear
austere
religious mostly peaceful coffee that is
my official title do you think the biden
campaign is delaying their vp pick
until as close to the election as
possible to avoid scrutiny of their vp
i think if they pick one now that would
shift the focus off of trump
and onto whatever wild-eyed radical
they put on the trojan horse
fair enough i mean i i think the biden
campaign is
delaying everything and they're delaying
everything because they don't have to
campaign
i think the biden campaign right now
believes that they are winning
and they're as long as they get to stay
in the basement and trump is not allowed
to hold rallies
and as long as you know until maybe the
last week or two the trump campaign was
kind of
falling apart that they're going to win
by doing nothing and so they're going to
do nothing
why why would they risk anything new
don't expect the biden campaign to do
anything including name their their vp
pick
until they are forced to by republicans
that's what that's that's on us we've
got to pressure them the trump
campaign's got to pressure them
we've got to use the political levers to
get biden's base to pressure him
we've got to use wedges to split the far
left
democratic party from joe biden on major
issues
that's on us we can't do that without a
campaign we can't do that with a virtual
digital campaign
that's controlled by the puppet masters
of the universe
we've got to get out there and engage in
real politics which means public which
means
real life that is the mission that we
have and if we
if we fail and if we loaf and if we sit
on our couches and take selfies
or take inadvertent selfies while
instagram spies on us
we'll be giving away a whole lot more
than just some data on our cell phone
that's our show i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
see you later
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there